foreign
the subject of this chapter is what
distinguishes chomsky's approach
fundamentally from structuralism let us
briefly recall in greatly simplified
form some properties of his generative
model
a generative grammar he says must render
explicitly implicit knowledge of the
speaker or the intelligence of the
reader
the term intelligence receives a special
definition here
even the most complete traditional
grammars forget to mention the simplest
characterizations
for example
with their instructions as the sole
indication one would have been unable to
generate any of the above sentences
in French nothing would prevent apriori
the production of the sequence
the grammar is very generative on the
model of La Grange
the grammar is very interesting
if we start with a definition that the
traditional French grammar of say gravis
gives of the adjective
crevice did not specify this because the
speaker of French knows intuitively that
one does not say this
on the other hand the French speaker
must learn by heart the formation of the
plural that distinguishes
from Naval
Naval
those are irregularities
furthermore Chomsky proposes the
construction of a formal model
starting from an axiom and a set of
well-defined rules the desired sequences
are generated mechanically
what was termed the base component of
the grammar was conceived in the
beginning as a finite set of rewriting
rules that is rules having the form Phi
yields PSI
which can be translated as follows each
time you encounter the element which is
to the left of the arrow you can replace
it by PSI
which is to the right of the arrow I
will not go into further detail here
but see Adrian ahmedian and Frank
henney's introduction to the principles
of transformational syntax or C.L
Baker's introduction to generative
transformational syntax
I will however give an idea of what the
base component of a grammar is with a
very simple example
imagine a language that has only three
words
Chloe and loves
the speakers of this language know
spontaneously that certain combinations
without repetition of these three words
belong to the language While others do
not
for example
loves Jean Chloe loves Croatia clue
Asian loves
Chloe loves Jill Jill loves Chloe
where Jill loves Chloe and Chloe loves
Jewel belong to the language
and all else do not belong to the
language
the problem is to render this knowledge
explicit
one can propose the following grammar
s yields n and v p meaning sentence is
Rewritten as noun plus verb phrase
VP yields vnn
meaning verb phrase is Rewritten as verb
plus noun
meaning noun is Rewritten as Jewel or
Chloe
the yields love meaning verb is
Rewritten as loves
following these deductions mechanically
if s then n plus v p Etc
one will arrive at the desired sequences
furthermore one can never deduce
undesirable sequences let us construct a
derivation
s is replaced by
n v p
acing v p by VN
n v n
replacing the first n by Jill
VN
replacing V by loves
Jewel loves n
replacing the second n by Chloe
Jewel loves Chloe
one cannot go further a string is
terminal
we can equally well represent the
derivation by a tree or phrase marker
this tree describes the structure of the
terminal elements of the sentence thus
we see that the relation of Jewel and of
Khloe with respect to the verb is not
symmetrical
a tree structure beginning with s
sentence
which is then broken down into n noun
nvp verb phrase
the noun is jul
the verb phrase is further broken down
into the verb loves and the noun Chloe
one can hardly doubt that the grammar of
a natural language is incomparably more
complicated
Chomsky has shown the three writing
rules no matter how complex they may be
are not sufficient for describing the
natural languages
the grammar of a language is thus a
model that must include several other
components in addition to the rewriting
rules of the base component
in his earliest writings Chomsky showed
that it is necessary to incorporate in
the grammar at least two other levels
the rewriting rules give the structure
of the sequences of words
it is necessary to add a more
phonological component and the
transformational component
the transformational rules are rules of
a different type which transform the
syntactic structures generated by the
rewriting rules into other structures
according to precise principles
the relation between the active and the
passive has usually been cited as an
example involving transformation
the evolution of this theory has led to
the complication of the model at certain
points and to its simplification at
others
later I will indicate the points at
which the model has evolved
the history of generative grammar seems
to fall into three main periods
which successively have placed in the
foreground one of the essential aspects
of the new Theory
the first which lasted from the
beginning of the 1950s to the middle of
the 1960s sought to make Linguistics a
science physics seemed to be the model
of reference
this is the period of The Logical
structure of linguistic Theory or
lslt as it will be cited
after that
from 1965 to 1970 the question of
semantics became more Central
must the meaning of words and sentences
be accounted for in the grammar and if
so in what fashion
very Lively controversy accompany the
different answers given
finally after 1970
research became oriented more toward the
problems posed by Universal grammar
to comply with the formal exigencies of
these discussions I have asked Nom
Chomsky to follow this thematic
chronology
the history of generative grammar
opposition to structuralism
generative grammar is born of the break
with and in opposition to structuralism
the latter in general conceived of
linguistics as a classificatory activity
you have given the discipline a logical
structure a scientific structure
the term science is perhaps honorific
my own inclination is to attach less
importance to the precise description of
some domains of linguistic data and to
the explanatory power and depth of
underlying principles
I take for granted that in something as
complex as the actual utilization of
language and the judgments about
language many systems enter into
interaction
no matter how careful our observations
how objective are methods and how
replicable our experiments
acts presented are in my opinion
of little interest in themselves
what is of interest is their bearing on
explanatory theories that seek to
formulate the fundamental principles of
the language faculty
speaking just for myself
organizing the facts of language does
not interest me very much
the notion facts of language has little
sense outside of at least an implicit
theory of language
one can perfectly well have different
interests
I'm simply trying to make clear what
interests me
frankly I do not believe that seeking to
account for all the facts constitutes a
reasonable goal
in contrast what seems important to me
is the discovery of facts that are
crucial for determining underlying
structure and Abstract hidden principles
if such principles do not exist
the Enterprise is not worth undertaking
if they do exist then facts are
interesting to me at least
insofar as they bear on the truth of
these principles the discovery of such
facts is often a creative achievement in
itself
and very much Theory related
the facts in any interesting sense of
that notion are not simply presented to
us
nor is it of great interest in my
opinion to present the facts in an exact
manner although of course the pertinent
facts
again a notion that is linked to Theory
must be presented in as precise a manner
as possible
as in physics
if you like
that is how it seems to me
at each stage in the development of
physics there have been innumerable
unexplained facts or facts that seem
totally incompatible with the theories
being actively pursued
to take a classic example consider the
facts of sorcery or of astrology
which seemed very well established by
the standards of Empirical research in
the period when classical Galilean
physics became established scientific
Doctrine
or to take a less exotic example
consider the problems encountered by
17th century physics in dealing with
observations by telescope
many of which were not understood until
quite recently
or simply the problem of explaining why
the apparent size and brightness of the
planets did not vary as predicted by
copernican Theory
as the distance between the planets
changes
or consider Galileo's inability to
explain why objects don't fly off the
Earth if it is indeed revolving on its
axis
the explanation only came later
without going into a detailed discussion
it is certainly true that throughout the
history of the serious Sciences
many problems in explaining facts were
put aside
in the hope that they would be explained
someday
to account for all the facts in the
physical world has never been the goal
of physics in the modern period
in the sense that some linguists think
that a grammar must account for all the
facts of language in the utilization of
language
the great success of physics is due in
part to the willingness to restrict
attention to the facts that seem crucial
at a particular level of understanding
and perhaps to look for quite exotic
facts that will be crucial for the
theory
without taking into account even evident
facts when these do not seem pertinent
to physical Theory
and to be quite honest sometimes even
when they appear inconsistent with it
as for those varieties of structuralism
or of descriptive Linguistics that are
interested primarily in the arrangement
of facts
one can doubtless say that my own goals
are not necessarily incompatible with
theirs
but that we are dealing with different
intellectual Enterprises
in my logical of linguistic Theory which
contains my doctoral thesis
I try to discuss these questions
I suggested there for the purposes of
linguistic Theory we should be concerned
with certain phenomena that were pretty
much excluded from the descriptive
Linguistics of that period
those facts relating to what has
sometimes been called the creative use
of language
conceived as normal usage of language
these facts have not been treated
systematically by traditional grammar or
by structural Linguistics although as I
have frequently pointed out they were a
classical concern for example and work
by Humboldt Paul yesperson and others
the traditional grammars even those of
great scope like jespersons present
innumerable examples of complex
structures
but do not give explicit principles for
determining that these structures and
others which somehow resemble them
belong to the language
while other imaginable structures do not
in fact
this question was not really raised
yes person I suppose did not have the
impression that there was something
fundamental missing in his presentation
despite his recognition of the
importance of what he called free
expressions
in presenting his innumerable examples
he thought that he had given an account
of the language so it appears
in reality his commentaries were not
sufficient because the appealed
implicitly on the intelligence of the
reader
to understand them and to use these
examples and his often insightful
commentary in the creation and
comprehension of new forms the reader
had to add his own intuitive knowledge
of language
structural grammars did not undertake
the task of studying a range of Highly
complex syntactic structures as the
traditional grammars did
this contribution of the intelligent
reader presupposed by previous grammars
must be made explicit if we hope to
discover the basic principles of
language
this is the first goal of generative
grammar
in psychological terms what is the
nature of the intuitive unconscious
knowledge which in particular
permits the speaker to use his language
at the time that question had not been
squarely faced
though it had occasionally been put
forth
and it remains a serious question today
in many crucial respects an unanswered
one
the second goal is to construct an
explanatory Theory
we have an at least potential
explanation when we can deduce certain
phenomena from general principles
that is when we can provide a deductive
chain of reasoning departing from these
principles
given certain particular facts
considered as boundary conditions
to be more concrete
let us take a well-known example
the behavior of the English auxiliary
system
one can I think explain some aspects of
this system on the basis of a certain
theory of transformational grammar and
certain given facts among them the
elementary examples of the auxiliary
system in simple declarative sentences
starting from these principles and
empirical facts
I tried to show that one could explain
the behavior of the auxiliary in a
variety of constructions
interrogative negative and so on
a third goal appeared clearly only later
at the end of the 50s
before that it was implicit
it had to do with considering the
general principles of language as the
properties of a biologically given
system that underlies the acquisition of
language
from this point of view
one might think of the boundary
conditions as the facts encountered by
someone who learns a language
what one tries to explain then is
essentially the knowledge of The
Language attained by the speaker
presented with such facts
to go back to the preceding example
if we assume that the speaker possesses
as part of his biological makeup the
general principles of transformational
grammar
and is presented with some subset of the
forms of the English auxiliary
then he would know because he could
deduce it the behavior of these elements
in other cases
that is the other cases would follow
from the simplest permissible rule
compatible with the given cases
this at least is the general pattern of
a possible explanation
thus my work sought to answer two
questions
first what is the system of linguistic
knowledge that has been attained and is
internally represented by a person who
knows some language
and second
how can we account for the growth and
attainment of such knowledge
the second question
can be thought of in psychological terms
how can knowledge be acquired
or alternatively as the question of how
we explain the phenomena of language
when did you think for the first time of
proposing an explanatory theory in
linguistics
that was what interested me about
Linguistics in the first place
as an undergraduate at the University of
Pennsylvania in the late 1940s
I did an undergraduate thesis called
morphophonemics of modern Hebrew
later expanded to a master's thesis with
the same title in 1951.
that work which has not been published
was a generative grammar in the
Contemporary sense
its primary focus was what is now called
generative phonology
but there was also a rudimentary
generative syntax
I suppose one might say that it was the
first generative grammar in the
Contemporary sense of the term
of course there were classical
precedents Panini's grammar of Sanskrit
is the most famous and important case
and at the level of morphology and
phonology
there is bloomfield's Menominee
morphophonemics
published only a few years earlier
though I did not know about it at the
time
anyway the central part of this project
was an attempt to demonstrate in
painstaking detail that the generative
grammar I presented was the simplest
possible grammar in a well-defined
technical sense
namely given a certain framework for the
formulation of rules and a precise
definition of simplicity
the grammar was locally optimal in the
sense that any interchange of order of
rules in a tightly ordered system of
many rules would lead to a less simple
grammar
reading back into this work the explicit
concerns of a later period
one might say then that the goal was to
show exactly how this grammar with its
empirical consequences
would be constructed by someone
initially equipped with the framework
for rules and the definition of
Simplicity the evaluation measure and
given a sufficient sample of the data
actually this was done in far greater
detail and scale than anything I've
attempted since
and was far too ambitious I suppose
that grammar did as I said contain a
rudimentary generative syntax
the grammar-associated phonetic
representation with what we would Now
call Base generated syntactic structure
parenthetically
this was a pre-transformational grammar
Harris's early work on Transformations
was then underway
and as a student of his I was familiar
with it
but I did not see then how this work
could be recast with the framework of
generative grammar that I was trying to
work out
in place of Transformations the grammar
had a complex system of indices assigned
to syntactic categories
which indicated syntactic relations
inexpressible within the framework of
segmentation and classification that was
later constructed in somewhat different
terms as the theory of phrase structure
grammar
since that time my major interest has
been to make precise the basic
principles which enter into the
knowledge of grammar that has been
attained by the speaker hearer
and beyond that to try to discover the
general theoretical principles which
account for the fact that this system of
knowledge rather than something else
develops in the mind when a person is
placed in a certain linguistic
environment
in a general way
I might say that I am still working very
much within the framework of that early
unpublished work
that is I think the right approach to
the fundamental theoretical issues is
the one attempted there
to make precise a certain format and
schematism for grammars
and to provide an evaluation procedure
or Simplicity measure that leads to the
choice of a particular system
a particular grammar that is of the
required form
namely the optimal most highly valued
system of the required form that is
compatible with the presented data
then what the language learner comes to
know is that most highly valued system
it is that system that underlies the
actual use of language by the person who
has gained this knowledge
I'll come back to this point
I continued this early work in The
Logical structure of language Theory
lslt
which was published in part only in
1975. 20 years after it was essentially
completed
the psychological point of view did not
begin to appear until the end of the 50s
especially with a very important review
article by Lees written for language
this was a review of syntactic
structures which appeared in 1957.
almost the same time as the book in it
Lee's brought up the issues of language
learning
I wrote on similar questions in the
years that followed
but we had been thinking about these
issues for some time
Morris Halley and Eric Lundberg among
others
one of the things that most interested
us was the critique of the behavioral
sciences
we were trying to work out a rather
different approach to cognitive
psychology
little of this appears in lslt because
it seemed to me too audacious and
premature
there is a more detailed discussion in
the introduction to The 1975 edition of
lslt
new theoretical positions were accorded
to the mixed reception in linguistic
circles
I remember reading review articles on
the first colloquia in which you
participated the Texas conference
the discussion was an epic confrontation
you opposed evaluation procedures
mechanisms that would tell which of two
grammars proposed to account for the
facts is the better one to the Discovery
procedures of the structure lists which
were designed to construct the grammar
directly from the facts
on this point one must distinguish
carefully among the several tendencies
that have been called structuralist
American descriptive Linguistics is one
of these
its Chief contribution in my opinion was
to raise for the first time a problem
that one could readily interpret as that
of explanation
or of the acquisition of language
what I mean is that the development of
Discovery procedures could have been
understood as an approach to a theory of
language acquisition
and also as an explanatory Theory
considered from the Dual perspective of
psychology and epistemology
it is interesting to see that that was
not the case
the linguists who were developing
Discovery procedures did not say here is
the Corpus the empirical conditions
imposed by the data our Discovery
procedures constitute the theory which
applied to the Corpus produces the
grammar
that grammar represents linguistic
knowledge in presenting this Theory we
have given an explanation for the fact
that a speaker Having learned a language
knows this and that the discovery
procedure is part of his genetic
equipment
and in applying it to the data of
experience he constructs this grammar
which represents his knowledge of
language
that would have been a reasonable way of
interpreting what they were doing
but they did not give such an
interpretation for various reasons
however that approach implicit in their
work seems to me the most important
contribution of this variety of
structuralism
I repeat
this is not their interpretation
but I believe it to be legitimate as a
reconstruction
even though it conflicts with what most
of the people who did this work actually
had in mind
to the best of my knowledge
in work that I was doing in the late
1940s and early 1950s
I tried to overcome some crucial
deficiencies in the discovery procedures
that had been developed and to make
these procedures explicit
while assuming in the back of my mind a
position concerning the so-called
psychological reality of these
procedures that was sharply in conflict
with prevailing assumptions in the field
as I understood them assumptions that
might be called fictionalist
it seems to have been generally assumed
that the discovery procedures could be
justified only in pragmatic terms as
providing an organization of the Corpus
that would be useful for one or another
purpose
there were exceptions for example
Charles hawkett who put forth an
explicitly realistic interpretation of
Discovery procedures
in an important brief article in 1948 in
the international Journal of American
linguistics
I was also taking for granted that the
discovery procedures were basically true
in the sense that one might think of
them as a representation of the
procedures that were actually employed
to provide the knowledge we have from
the data we are given
for a long time I thought that the
discovery procedures appearing in the
literature were correct in their
Essentials that is that the methods
employed by structural linguists like
zelig Harris with whom I was studying
were in principle correct
and that only some refinements were
necessary to make them work
I spent quite a lot of time and energy
for about five or six years I guess
trying to overcome some obvious defects
of these procedures
so that they would be able to produce a
correct grammar with infinite
descriptive scope from a finite Corpus
of the language
that evidently is the proper formulation
of the task
if we think of these procedures as in
effect a learning theory for human
language
there were thus two interrelated
questions
is it correct to give a psychological
interpretation to these methods are
these Discovery procedures the ones
which express correctly the biological
given that makes the acquisition of
language possible
note that we cannot properly pose the
second question unless we accept a
positive reply to the first
we cannot inquire into the correctness
of methods without considering them to
be an expression more precisely an
intended expression of some
psychological reality
it is only under this realist
interpretation that the question of
correctness or truth arises
but again this realist interpretation
was not that of Harris and most others
who had worked out the more elaborate
procedures of analysis
more and more I began to realize that
the answer to the second question was
negative
these procedures had insurmountable
defects
they were wrong in principle
the right approach seemed to involve
principles that were more abstract more
indirect
I slowly came to believe that it was
necessary to assume general principles a
general abstract schematism which when
confronted with the given data would
yield a grammar representing linguistic
knowledge along the lines I mentioned
earlier
on the psychological level structuralist
Discovery procedures correspond
essentially to The empiricist View
According to which the acquisition of
knowledge requires operations of
classification and induction
it is in that sense that structural
Linguistics is linked to empiricism
in either the European version with
trubitskoi who was quite concerned with
these questions or the American version
the procedures are essentially taxonomic
based on techniques of segmentation and
classification
that proceed gradually toward ever
larger linguistic units
the principles must be totally different
today I am convinced of that
one must begin by characterizing
potential systems of knowledge with the
help of principles which express the
biological given
these principles determine the type of
grammars that are available in
principles
they are associated with an evaluation
procedure which given possible grammars
selects the best one
the evaluation procedure is also part of
the biological given
the acquisition of language thus is a
process of selection of the best grammar
compatible with the available data
if the principles can be made
sufficiently restrictive
there will also be a kind of Discovery
procedure
in some sense there must be such a
procedure since knowledge is attained
but of a very different sort from what
was contemplated in structuralist theory
this conception of the nature of human
knowledge and particularly of language
is very different from the empiricist
conception
because one assumes the general form of
the resulting system of knowledge to be
given in advance
the system is not constructed gradually
step by step by induction segmentation
and classification
generalization and abstraction and so on
consequently I think we might identify
three fundamental issues that arise in
comparing structuralist Linguistics to
generate of grammar
first with regard to the goal of
explicit characterization of the
attained linguistic knowledge second the
interpretation of the procedures
are the analytic procedures of B block
of Harris of troubetskoi Simply ways of
organizing a corpus
or do they constitute empirical
hypotheses that are strong and
interesting with respect to
psychological reality and specifically
to biologically given innate structure
on this point work and generative
grammar has characteristically taken a
very explicit position
yes we propose such empirical hypotheses
consequently we consider pertinent all
data that have any bearing on the
validity of these hypotheses
at least in my opinion
it has always seemed evident that only
the realist interpretation of linguistic
Theory whether procedural or not
provides the basis for significant
discipline
one that is worth pursuing
trans instructureless Linguistics have
varied on this question and there are
also some problems of interpretation
I believe that Jacobson and troubitsukoi
did take a position close to that later
adopted within generative grammar
they speak of psychological reality it
seems to me as did Edwards appear for
example quite explicitly
furthermore at least in phonology
they postulated Universal structural
principles and even in a sense
evaluation procedures in the form of
considerations of symmetry minimizing
redundancy and so on
Harris on the contrary
rejected the realist psychological
interpretations quite explicitly
at least in his early work
I'm not sure that this is also true of
his more recent work since the late 60s
in his methods and other works up to the
early 60s
he presented his theory as providing
various alternatives for organizing data
the same is true of block and others
though not of Hockett
finally the third question deals with
the nature of correct procedure
is this a discovery procedure inductive
and taxonomic
or is the proper approach of something
like the rationalist type that is a
characterization of the general form of
knowledge knowledge of the language in
this case
with methods for choosing among
alternative realizations of this General
system under the empirical conditions
given by experience
I think it is proper to conceive of the
theory of distinctive features and
phonology and the various proposals
concerning relative preference
marketness as a schema for a system of
knowledge
if not an acquisition model
though it is worth noting that
troubetskoy in his phonological work
sought to furnish taxonomic procedures
in relation to the second Point I've
noted that there are many divergences
over the definition given to the
activity of linguistics
the analyzes the theories they present
are they simply intellectual games or do
they seek to establish the truth even
partially of an objective law imposed
upon something real
the question is how does one interpret a
discovery procedure
is it solely a matter of organizing
linguistic data or a way of expressing a
psychological reality
it is interesting to look more closely
at the practice of the linguists who
argued explicitly that they were simply
providing techniques for compact
organization of data
that practice rests upon a tacit belief
to the contrary
and this holds throughout the entire
development of structural linguistics
constantly whenever someone proposed a
method or procedure someone else would
point out that this procedure leads to
undesirable results
then certain Corrections and
improvements were proposed
in this way procedures were constantly
refined
but what meaning can we give to the
notion undesirable result
there is no such notion at least in any
interesting sense
if all that is at stake is a way of
organizing data then there can only be
results that are neither good nor bad
apart from minimal considerations of
redundancy or consistency
one cannot be right or wrong in
classifying data in a theoretical vacuum
consequently to the degree that one
recognizes tacitly the existence of such
Notions as good results versus unwanted
results it becomes evident that one is
committed to some notion of
psychological reality that is of truth
no matter how much the commitment is
denied
however the explicit rejection of such a
commitment makes it very difficult to
arrive at such an interpretation of much
of this work
which might find its rationale in this
interpretation
two definitions of transformation
the concept of transformation is a
fundamental one in your theory it is
also one of its principal Innovations
in your model the transformational
component operates on the output of the
base component the rewriting rules it
takes phrase structures trees and
transforms them into other phrase
structures trees
but the linguist zelig Harris had
already used the term transformation
the distinction between the two uses of
the term has often been poorly
understood
could you state it precisely
Harris's concept of transformation was
not strictly speaking linguistic in its
origin
or more precisely
not a concept that belongs to the theory
concerned with the grammatical structure
of sentences
Harris developed this concept as part of
a study of discourse in the late 1940s
the linguistic theory he had presented
in his methods offered only tools for
describing units that do not exceed the
length of a single sentence
when he attempted to extend these
methods to the structure of discourse he
observed that once that the methods of
segmentation and classification devised
for the grammar of sentences did not
lead to any useful result
he therefore sought a way to reduce the
set of complex sentences of discourse to
a form in which they would be
susceptible to analysis by the methods
devised for sentences and their parts
he proposed the use of certain
transformations to normalize the
discourse to transform complex sentences
into uniform simple structures
to which the methods of structural
Linguistics might apply
segmentation of sequences substitution
of elements classification and so on
for Harris
Transformations were systematic
relations between sentences between
surface structures
technically the transformation in this
sense is an unordered pair of linguistic
structures taken to be structurally
equivalent in a certain sense to give a
concrete example think of two linguistic
structures
each on one side of a double arrow
each structure described by succession
of grammatical categories of which it is
composed
here is how one formulates the active
passive relation within this framework
noun X Plus verb plus noun Y is
equivalent to noun y plus is plus verb
in past participle plus by plus noun X
the two structures on either side of the
arrow in such formulas are held to be
equivalent in the following sense
if we choose a particular noun say John
for noun X and a particular noun say
Mary for noun y
and a particular verb say c for verb
then the two substitution instances that
is John sees Mary on the left and Mary
is seen by John on the right have the
same degrees of acceptability as
sentences
such equivalences can be used to
normalize a discourse in the following
manner if we are given a sentence in a
discourse in one of the two forms
then we can replace it by the
corresponding sentence in the other form
by continuing to apply these equivalence
transformations to a discourse we can
reduce the sentences to similar forms to
which the substitution procedures
developed for the grammar of sentences
can be applied
and we can construct substitution
classes of words that play more or less
the same role in discourse
these discourse categories must not be
confused with the lexical or phrase
categories of the language
this is the basic idea of discourse
analysis as Harris has developed it in
various Publications since about 1950.
what is relevant in this context
is the transformational relations in
Harris's sense were developed in the
course of an attempt to extend
structural methods to the analysis of
discourse
on the theoretical level one essential
characteristic of Harris's
Transformations is that each is
established independently of other
aspects of grammar as Harris has
emphasized
each transformation is established once
and for all from observation and
evidence on the basis of the
distributional conditions I have just
described
each transformational relation exists
independently of what is true or false
for the rest of the language
a transformation is in effect a
generalization about the acceptability
of instances of two sentence forms
and that factual generalization is true
or false quite apart from anything we
may subsequently discover about the
language in question or the theory of
language or from any other source say
psychological experiment
this account is a natural one within the
general approach of Harris's methods a
non-psychological conception of
linguistics
Harris rejects the idea that the
language of a particular person or
Community can be regarded as a
well-defined set of sentences with
structures characterized by grammatical
principles that are true or false
at least in the framework of his methods
which provided the background for the
development of the notion transformation
a grammatical description is as he put
it a compact account of a collection of
data
and thus can be incorrect only through
inadvertence
for example
if it states that some element in the
data set has an observable property that
it does not have
transformational analysis in his sense
is simply another way of describing the
given collection of observations
and it is therefore quite natural to
describe a transformation as a
generalization stating that data
exhibits some property
in this case the property of equal
acceptability under systematic
substitution as described a moment ago
a grammatical description in this sense
is quite different from a partial theory
in some natural science for example
in the Natural Sciences two theories may
be in Conflict even if they agree on
available data and the scientists will
then search for new data to choose
between them
proceeding on the realist assumption
that what the theories allege about the
entities postulated in them is true or
false and therefore susceptible to
further test
but Harris at least through the early
60s took the position that alternative
linguistic descriptions cannot be in
conflict in this sense
at least that is what I take him to be
maintaining and work up to the time of
his paper on transformational analysis
in language
in lslt and subsequent work in
generative grammar Transformations are
defined in a very different manner
perhaps I should have used a different
term instead of adapting Harris's to the
quite different context of generative
grammar
in lslt for example
a transformation is not a relation
between two sets of sentences or between
two surface structures
it is a rule within a system of rules
that assign structural descriptions to
an infinite class of sentences
in the derivation of a particular
sentence a transformational rule applies
to an abstract representation of this
sentence
and transforms it into another abstract
representation
the initial representation is the
so-called deep structure which is
transformed step by step into terminal
or Surface structure
in the framework of generative grammar
equivalence relations of the kind that
Harris uses to establish a
transformation can only suggest the
existence of a transformation but not
establish it
for example
in English it is true that the
appropriate substitution relations
between the active and the passive hold
by and large
sincerity frightens Paul is just as good
a sentence as Paul is frightened by
sincerity while Paul frightened
sincerity is just as bizarre as
sincerity is frightened by Paul
but no matter how precisely such
substitution relations hold
they do not suffice to establish the
existence of a transformation relating
active and passive forms
rather empirical arguments are needed to
show that within the schematism of
permissible rule systems the optimal
grammar includes such a transformation
furthermore even if such a
transformation is postulated on the
basis of some empirical argument
it would not relate sincerity frightens
Paul and Paul is frightened by sincerity
rather the postulated passive
transformation would figure in the
derivation of Paul is frightened by
sincerity
from its abstract deep structure but not
in the derivation of sincerity frightens
Paul
from its abstract deep structure
the two deep structures might be similar
or even identical and The derivations
Identical apart from this transformation
but that is the only sense in which one
might say that the two sentences are
related by this transformation
thus the notion of transformation
quite different from the one that Harris
developed
furthermore
within the theoretical framework of
generative grammar a transformation is
never incorrigible in Harris's sense
no matter how powerful the empirical
evidence in favor of a grammar
containing some transformation
subsequent evidence might indicate that
the grammar is wrong
and some other grammar permitted by the
same general theory is right
or that the general theory is wrong and
some different set of principles with a
different schematism for grammar is
right
nor is it possible to determine a priori
what kinds of evidence will prove
relevant to such conclusions
a grammar is essentially like a
hypothesis in the Natural Sciences
concerning some subject matter never
finally established no matter how strong
the empirical evidence
and the same is true of a particular
subhypothesis of the grammar to the
effect that it contains a certain
transformational rule
I hope this helps to clarify the
difference between the two conceptions
mathematics and linguistics
generative grammars were born of a
meeting between mathematics and
linguistics
can you give more precise information
about this birth
I should distinguish between two
questions
the first relates to a problem that has
already been raised
how can linguistic knowledge be
explicitly characterized
an explicit characterization must
ultimately be a formalized theory
this remark may also be extended to the
problem of acquisition of language and
the related matter of explanatory Theory
in the sense of our earlier discussion
explanations exist to the degree that
the general principles are precise
in principle formalized starting from
such principles one can construct a
deductive argument leading to the
phenomena that are to be explained
thus a certain quasi-mathematical mode
of expression is presupposed in the
overall program
but one that is quite unsophisticated
we want to formulate precise principles
and precise rules within a formalized
system
it turns out that the way to speak
precisely is by formalization
but it would not be correct to consider
that as mathematics
for example some variety of recursive
function Theory provides the means in
principle to express linguistic rules
but up to that point that is
formalization not mathematics
mathematical Linguistics begins when one
studies abstract properties of the
formalization
abstracting away from particular
realizations
the subject exists in a serious sense
only insofar as non-trivial theorems can
be proven or at least considered
the Viewpoint is very different
certain mathematical theories have
seduced many linguists
I'm thinking of their historic
encounters with telecommunications
engineers
well at the end of the 40s and the
beginning of the 50s there were
important developments in the
mathematical theory of communication
information Theory and the theory of
automata
technically models such as finite State
Markov sources were proposed
very often it was supposed that these
models were appropriate for the
description of language
Jacobson referred to this vaguely but
hocket utilized them quite explicitly
in 1955 he proposed a theory of language
structure based on a Markov Source model
borrowed from the mathematical theory of
communication
similar theories were developed by
psychologists Engineers mathematicians
all these theories left me very
skeptical
I became interested in the relevant
mathematics at first largely because I
wanted to prove that these models were
not appropriate for the grammar of
natural language
what was the atrioli reason for your
skepticism and intuition
an intuition again found that on the
same anti-emperism
in my view a finite State Markov Source
model
might reasonably be considered as
characterizing something like the outer
limits of empiricist learning theory
in fact
a mathematical psychologist and logician
Patrick soopies gave precise expression
to this Intuition or one version of it a
few years ago
he proved that a certain very rich
version of stimulus response learning
theory
must remain within the limits of finite
State sources of the kind we have been
discussing
he considered this to be a positive
result
to me it seemed to be a negative result
the reason is this
as has been known for a long time
even Elementary systems of knowledge
cannot be represented in terms of finite
State Markov sources
for example
our knowledge of English or even much
simpler systems such as propositional
calculus
as a consequence supi says result showed
that knowledge which we possess cannot
even be approached at the limit
a fortury not attained by the Learning
Theory he was considering
this constituted a final step in a
complete refutation of this learning
theory and consequently less powerful
theories
I did not believe in theories of
language based on the Markov Source
model
which seemed to me to inherit the
defects of empiricist learning theory
however
to know whether they were correct or not
it was necessary to wait until they were
presented in a precise manner then the
essential question could be posed
do properties of natural languages exist
which cannot be expressed in any of
these systems
and such properties do exist
when did you demonstrate that
after lslt was completed
the first version of this manuscript
completed in 1955 involved a good deal
of formalization but no mathematics
shortly after I moved from the Society
of fellows at Harvard to the research
laboratory of electronics at MIT
there there was a great deal of quite
Justified interest in the mathematical
theory of communication and also a great
deal of less Justified faith and the
potential for the study of language
offered by Markov Source models and the
like which had aroused considerable
enthusiasm among Engineers mathematical
psychologists and some linguists
as soon as the question was clearly
formulated it was immediately obvious
that these models were not adequate for
the representation of language
this observation was published in
syntactic structures and along with some
other material in a more technical
article in 1956
after that a certain branch of
mathematical Linguistics developed
which occupied itself primarily with the
formal properties of systems that were
considerably richer
called phrase structure grammars the
most interesting class of these systems
turned out to be what are called
technically context-free phrase
structure grammars
since the end of the 50s there has been
quite a lot of work on the formal
properties of various types of grammars
on their generative power their
properties and relations and so on and
today this study constitutes a small
branch of mathematics
the French mathematician MP
schutzenberger made quite interesting
contributions to this field
which developed independently of
linguistics
yes
and I hope that these studies will
continue to be pursued
as well as the mathematical
investigation of transformational
grammars
there has been some interesting recent
work by Stanley Peters and Robert
Ritchie on this latter topic
returning to the earlier point
it seems clear that the empiricist
learning theories are much too limited
to be adequate
and it is even possible to demonstrate
this if we accept the assumption that
finite State Markov sources are the
richest systems that can be attained by
such theories
at the limit
this conclusion does not seem to be
unreasonable to me although naturally it
is not a precise conclusion because the
notion empiricist theory is not well
defined
did you link your critique of these
theories right away to the critique of
structural linguistics
well indirectly
these theories were then very much in
fashion and they even aroused a certain
degree of euphoria
I think it's fair to say
in the intellectual Amelia of Cambridge
there was a great impact of the
remarkable technological developments
associated with World War II
computers Electronics Acoustics
mathematical theory of communication
cybernetics
all the technological approaches to
human behavior enjoyed an extraordinary
Vogue
the human Sciences were being
reconstructed on the basis of these
Concepts it was all connected
as a student at Harvard in the early
1950s
all of this had a great effect on me
some people myself included
were rather concerned about these
developments
in part for political reasons
at least as far as my personal
motivations were concerned
for political reasons
yes because this whole complex of ideas
seemed linked to potentially quite
dangerous political currents
manipulative and connected with
behaviorist concepts of human nature
thus your skepticism had political
causes
yes in part
but of course these motivations were
irrelevant to showing that all this was
wrong as I thought it was
I believe that these theories could not
really offer what they promised as soon
as they were analyzed carefully they
unraveled
though not without leaving substantive
and important contributions
we have seen vast programs of research
on artificial intelligence develop
based on the Apparently infinite
capacities of computers
artificial intelligence came a little
later as an outgrowth of what was then
called cybernetics
the situation in this respect is
paradoxical
in General Physics and Technology permit
the growth of human capacities in
performance sometimes with the aid of
quite simple instruments
with artificial intelligence the most
advanced technology is developed to
obtain the most limited results
well below the capacity of the most
stupid creature
I'm afraid that much of the work in this
field relies on ideas that are too
Elementary and superficial to shed light
on the question of human intelligence
this need not be the case
and perhaps someday will not be the case
but it has been true so far by and large
and the field has also suffered from
quite irresponsible claims
the same is true in the behavioral
sciences
for example Skinner's work on verbal
Behavior
that work published in 1957
was presented 10 years earlier as the
William James lectures
it immediately gained great influence w
v Quinn George Miller and many others
wrote and talked about it with
considerable enthusiasm
it was quite the rage at about the time
that I came to Cambridge in 1951 at
Harvard
one could have thought in fact some
people did think that computers were
going to permit the automation of
Discovery procedures in linguistics
the idea would be to present a corpus of
material to the computer so that it
would work out the grammar of this text
on the assumption that the taxonomic
procedures of analysis that had been
developed were in essence sufficient and
adequate to determine grammatical
structure
it was quite generally supposed at least
in the intellectual environment here in
Cambridge
that the scenarian theory of behavior
approached adequacy
and that the Notions developed within
the theory of communication in
particular the Markov Source model
furnished a general framework for the
study of language
but when I began to study these topics I
was quickly convinced that the
prevailing assumptions were false
and the popular models inadequate
for reasons which were not independent
but had significant links as I've
already said with empiricist Dogma
first steps
what were your first contacts with the
linguistic community
hostile full of conflict
not exactly
in the beginning we ignored each other
for example almost no one paid any
attention to that first work I mentioned
to you on the generative grammar of
modern Hebrew
but that was the work of a student
and I did not expect that anyone would
pay attention to it as far as I know
only two linguists showed any interest
in it
Henry hernix Vault an indo-europeanist
with whom I studied at the University of
Pennsylvania and Bernard block the
well-known Yale phonologist
however
outside the field of linguistics proper
the work attracted the attention of
yehoshua bar Hillel who was then here in
Cambridge
we became very close friends
he made some excellent suggestions for
example he suggested very persuasively
that I should be much more radical and
should postulate much more abstract
underlying representations
similar to those postulated for earlier
stages of the language
to explain contemporary forms
that turned out to be a very good idea
the significance of his suggestion
became apparent much later in generative
phonology
I recast the Hebrew grammar completely
following this suggestion in 1951
improving it considerably I thought
Quine expressed some interest in the
methodological aspect
particularly the problem of constructing
a Simplicity measure for linguistic
Theory
and encouraged me to work further on
that
as did Nelson Goodman
but that was about all
among the linguists no one showed any
interest in that type of work
I wasn't particularly Disturbed or
surprised
I did not think myself that I was doing
linguistics in a sense I was completely
schizophrenic at that time
I still thought that the approach of
American structural Linguistics was
essentially right
as I told you I spend a great deal of
time trying to improve and to formalize
Discovery procedures
in order to overcome their obvious
defects
but once they were made precise they led
manifestly to the wrong results
still for quite a long time I thought
that the mistake was mine due to wrong
formulations
in 1953 I published an article in the
Journal of symbolic logic in which I
tried to develop a discovery procedure
that I hoped might be the basis for
something that would really work
that for me was real linguistics
what I was doing otherwise
attempting to construct an explanatory
theory of generative grammar
seemed to me a different kind of work on
the side so to speak
among my contemporaries
there were a few who found that work
interesting
the only one who had always thought I
should pursue this work and drop the
whole Discovery procedure business was
Morris Halley
he was then a graduate student at
Harvard as I was too
and was also teaching at the same time
at MIT
we met in 1951 became close friends and
had endless discussions
he thought that these Discovery
procedures did not make any sense
I don't remember his arguments but I do
remember disagreeing with him at that
time
by 1953
I came to the same conclusion
if the discovery procedures did not work
it was not because I had failed to
formulate them correctly
but because the entire approach was
wrong
in retrospect I cannot understand why it
took me so long to reach this conclusion
I remember exactly the moment when I
finally felt convinced
on board ship in Mid-Atlantic aided by a
bout of seasickness on a rickety tub
that was listing noticeably
it had been sunk by the Germans and now
was making its first voyage after having
been salvaged
it suddenly seemed that there was a good
reason the obvious reason
why several years of intense effort
devoted to improving Discovery
procedures had come to not
while the work I had been doing during
the same period on generative grammars
and explanatory Theory an almost
complete isolation
seem to be consistently yielding
interesting results
once I had recognized that
progress was very rapid
in the next year and a half I wrote lslt
which was about 1 000 typed pages
and almost all of what was contained in
syntactic structures and the 1958 Texas
conference paper and so on
as for the reception accorded to lslt
there is little to say
I've already told you that I did not
have the impression the reaction on the
part of linguists was surprising
I offered lslt to the MIT press
who refused it
quite rightly I think because at that
time the situation was very unfavorable
for a general book on that subject
especially won by an unknown author
I also submitted a technical article on
Simplicity and explanation to the
journal word
at the suggestion of Roman Jacobson
but it was rejected virtually by return
mail
so I had little hope of seeing any of
this work published at least in a
linguistic Journal
but frankly that did not trouble me
greatly
I had a research position at the
research laboratory of electronics at
MIT
which I obtained thanks to Morris Halley
and Roman Jacobson and I taught
scientific French and scientific German
though I was barely competent
and also some undergraduate Linguistics
philosophy and logic
I did not have any problem making a
living
and was free to do the work that
interested me
I should emphasize that although there
was very little interest in the work I
was doing
at least among linguists I had
absolutely no cause for complaint as far
as working conditions were concerned
on the contrary
I was extremely fortunate and knew it
studying at Penn with zelig Harris and
Nelson Goodman was a highly stimulating
experience
and I was very fortunate to be able to
continue discussing the work I was doing
with Harris
particularly while I was at Harvard from
1951 to 1955 at the Society of fellows
where I had no responsibilities and was
free to do as I wished with all the
facilities of Harvard available
a remarkable opportunity
I spent a good deal of time in courses
seminars discussions primarily with
philosophers at Harvard Quine Austin who
visited Harvard then white and others
it was a very Lively and stimulating
period in the Cambridge area
for a student with my particular
interests
the research climate at MIT was close to
Ideal
I could not possibly have obtained a
position in linguistics anywhere
I really was not professionally
qualified by the standards of the field
at MIT
there were no entrenched academic
strongholds in the areas that interested
me
Morris Halley and I and a few others
were free to pursue our research
and later
to design a program of Graduate Studies
this absence of established structure
along with the general Spirit of
encouragement for Innovation that seemed
promising
made it possible for Linguistics to
flourish at MIT
in a way that for us at least
would have been virtually out of the
question elsewhere
George Miller who was then in the
Harvard psychology department also
became interested
and we did some work together in the
mid-50s
he went on to develop an entirely new
domain of psycholinguistics
with his help I was able to spend a
rewarding year at The Institute for
advanced study in Princeton in 1958
through 1959
I should also mention my close friend
Eric lenberg who at that time was
beginning his extremely interesting
studies in the biology of language
working along rather similar lines
later on these topics began to gain some
attention among linguists at first at
the Texas conferences in 1958 and 1959
organized by Archibald Hill to which I
was invited
the discussions were animated and sharp
as you pointed out before
unfortunately the proceedings of the
1959 conference were never published
there I presented a paper on the
generator phonology of English
in which I approached that subject very
much in the manner of my work on Hebrew
10 years before
but this time with much more confidence
in the approach
in general I published virtually nothing
except in journals that were outside the
field of linguistics in those years
questions of generative grammar
attracted the attention of linguists
primarily as a result of a publication
of a thorough review by Robert Lee's of
syntactic structures in 1957 in language
the monograph which appeared in Holland
would not have been known I imagine had
it not been for that review article
discussion moved to a more General Forum
in 1962. at the international Congress
of linguists which was held that year at
MIT
I gave a talk there
which was later published as a monograph
in a revised form
current issues in linguistic Theory
in that talk I tried to explain in a
fairly comprehensive manner what seemed
to me to be the essential differences
between generative grammar and
structural linguistics
but it was still somewhat difficult to
publish in the United States
although the situation had improved
greatly with the publication of very
important work by Robert Lee's G.H
Matthews and Edward Klima
did you now begin to teach linguistics
yes
at the beginning of the 60s we began a
program of Graduate Studies as I
mentioned we were able to develop our
program at MIT because in a sense
MIT was outside the American University
system
there were no large Departments of
humanities or the related social
sciences at MIT
consequently we could build up a
Linguistics apartment without coming up
against problems of rivalry and academic
bureaucracy
here we were really part of the research
laboratory of electronics
that permitted us to develop a program
very different from any other and quite
independent
about the same time a graduate program
in psychology was established at MIT
under Hans Lucas toiber's Direction
and a little later a graduate program in
philosophy was set up
both developed in a way that was quite
congenial to our work and there had been
a good deal of interaction among
students and faculty
including joint appointments and jointly
taught courses
that continues and I expect that there
will be even closer integration of these
fields along with related areas in
engineering and computer science
it seems to me that there is a natural
emerging discipline of cognitive
psychology in which these various
threads come together
and within which Linguistics can find an
appropriate place
the first students
who were the first students and the
first researchers of that new program
Maurice Halley was already working on a
generative phonology of Russia in the
1950s
and we also work together on the
generative phonology of English at first
jointly with Fred lukoff together with
Lee's Matthews Klima and lukoff I was at
least in principle part of a research
project on machine translation in the
research laboratory of electronics
headed by Victor ingvi but the linguists
with the exception perhaps of Matthews
were not much interested in the applied
problems of machine translation as far
as I can remember
at the end of the 50s Matthews who was a
specialist in American Indian languages
and had a good mathematical background
as well
produced a very important grammar of
hidatsa
in the technical sense of the term
Robert Lee's was our first student
though in reality a colleague
he presented his PhD thesis on English
nominalizations in 1960
but actually he received an engineering
degree
claima who worked with us received his
PhD degree at Harvard on historical
syntax he also published a very
important and influential article on
negation
when the graduate program began Jerry
Fodor and Jerry Katz were here as was
Paul postal John vertel who was also on
the machine translation program was
beginning his work on Humboldt and
related topics at that time
and MP schutzenberger was visiting from
France
after that things went very fast
that was the birth of the standard
Theory
yes it was at that period that what was
called the standard theory was
formulated with major contributions by
Fodor Katz and postal and many students
in the new graduate program
a large number of whom are now among the
most productive scholars in the field
which has really changed quite
dramatically since the period we have
just been discussing